remember a few years ago when they
wanted to draft Johnny Manziel and
Stephen Jones talked his father off the
ledge and they did not draft Johnny
Manziel I believe it was Zack Martin
that they drafted James Slater from NFL
Network back on the phone with his Janet
you there I am and I actually remember
that dress very well because I was
covering ATT stadium and I remember when
Johnny Manziel fell and he was available
and everybody knew that he was gonna
pull the trigger like how could he not
had so glowing we talked about Manziel
and of course we had heard about and
seen him around Dallas and thought this
would be a terrible idea for the
organization and wiser
wisdom prevailed and they ended up with
Zack Martin who has been you know
obviously a hallmark piece of this you
know this offensive line and with a lot
of the reason why this team was as
successful as they were last night well
outside of Ezekiel Elliott the the
strength of this team obviously the
offensive line dak Prescott has played
well they look fantastic last night
there was a pregame speech that that
Jason Garrett gave to the team not
necessarily known for pregame speeches
Jana did you hear about this and know
what he said to the guys so here's the
thing about Jason Garrett that is so
fascinating to me I feel like there's a
lot of coaches in the league to like you
to talk about what they do how they
motivate their players it typically gets
out about you know how they encourage
them we don't always hear that from
Jason Garrett but as I've done some sort
of digging in the last couple of weeks
because it has seemed like his seat is
about as hot as it's ever been I've
always laughed off this notion but it's
a hot heat because I've always felt like
it's lukewarm based on his relationship
with the Jones family and also the way
that his players have always so publicly
supported him and one of his former
players told me just a few weeks ago he
said you know Jamie you guys don't see
how accountable he holds us score how
tough some of our practices are I said
no I'm actually not familiar with that
you know that's if anything it's what us
in the media typically knock him for
because we don't hear about it and
Travis Frederick was on the radio this
morning talking about that pregame
speech and he said that Jason Garrett
essentially has these speeches
throughout the week there's a theme
there's a monster and it sort of starts
on Wednesday and then it culminates on
Saturday
but it was Shawn Lee who really came out
instead this speech this one in
particular was one of the best he'd ever
heard
so whatever it was that he said and
we'll do some digging when we're in the
locker room this week really got this
team you know on the right page and as
much as people you know want to move on
from Jason Garrett I've maintained that
the reason why he has continued to work
in Dallas is because of the love that
this locker room continues to have for
Jason I talked to players both privately
and publicly on this and have over the
years and they have always supported
that coach is there a number of playoff
games a number of wins that he has to
get to to keep his job I don't feel like
Jerry Jones is anxious to pull the
trigger on Jason Garrett I feel like he
would have done this a long time ago now
I know this year's a little different
and it could still end in a
disappointing season if they beat the
Eagles they you know they're gonna be
headed to the postseason assuming that
they can wrap things up and get home
field advantage what what does Jason
Garrett have to do to keep his job so
here's how I would break this down three
Dan
Ian rossport came out with report
yesterday and I had heard whispers of it
and then later confirmed you know the
Jones family did in fact use bat-channel
this offseason after that Rams loss they
were absolutely livid keep in mind
that's following that Packers divisional
loss so they used back channels to sort
of he engaged the possibility of
bringing someone like Sean Payton here
that of course didn't work out they had
already announced a few months before
that they were going to put Jason
Garrett on sort of a prove-it deal you
know here's you've got one year left in
your contract we're not going to give
you an extension which Jason was none
too pleased with but she was credit
continue to get this team rallied and
and got them to play and I had somebody
within the organization say to me he's
coaching his tail off this was ahead of
the season so they were noticing that I
can't then we've heard you know these
discussions that I had reported that
Steven Jones but in the last few months
has talked to Urban Meyer and the
Cowboys are interested in him now Jerry
Jones shot down that report and they
will maintain that they have not been
doing these coaching searches fine but I
would argue that as mad as they've been
with Chase
Garrett and as frustrated as they've
been with Jason Garrett he wants him
succeed the Jones family thinks very
highly of Jason Garrett there was that
report a few weeks ago that the Giants
would be interested in Jason I
maintained that if Jason or not to get
brought back here by Dallas
I believe the Redskins would be in play
Cleveland is Mert he had a lot of family
so I think Ohio would be interesting
especially the way that he is with good
young players he certainly wouldn't be
the type of guy that would love as focal
quarterback as Baker Mayfield but I
think the players learn to respect him
dak Prescott loves Jason Garrett might I
point out to you and so and I'm
listening to cherry who sort of been on
this emotional roller coasters because
he wants to win so bad he wanted these
guys to win he wanted this coach to win
he said something very interesting last
night he said when he was asked about if
this wind causes him to reassess his
thoughts on the future of this team and
coaching staff and he said and that
implies I had concluded and assessed the
future and that's not correct I had not
reached that point what it does remind
me of that the seasons not over
he also said there's nothing I'd like
more than to ride his coattails with
fairy tale here couple weeks ago it was
Jerry Jones who after blasting Jason and
the coaching staff after lost the
Patriots it was after that Bills law
came out and said that at first see is
the opportunity right of a hell of a
comeback story and then he says to us
reporters do you guys believe in
Redemption I'm a Redemption man so I've
been sort of joking on my podcast
that we do on the heard the Boys & Girls
podcast I said prepare yourselves for
the possibility I believe there is a
scenario as crazy as it sounds to people
I just I believe this if Jerry can't go
out there and land the Sean Payton's of
the world and he's got to go and go with
an unproven NFL guy or you know one of
these younger college coaches and that
rules of the world that link to Riley's
and and Jason starts creating buzz among
some of these other NFC East teams and
there's a possibility they could lose
them prepare yourselves for the
possibility that if they go and they win
the divisional game and it looks like he
lifted this team up I think he could
give
Jiri the sort of edge in the hope and
the idea you know maybe we'll bring
Jason back
I'm just saying prepare for the
possibility I'm on board I was saying
the Brockman earlier I feel like if he
wins a playoff game that he's gonna be
around and you're inside you know that
Jerry wants nothing more than for Jason
to be successful they're they're
comfortable there they have a management
structure that in Jerry's mind has
worked for them for quite some time and
Jason for the most part seems to be
comfortable with that that's interesting
about the Cleveland situation and
Garrett being a commodity potentially
you know with the New York Giants is
there a is there a team let's assume
that they win the division and they host
a playoff game is there a team that you
feel like the Cowboys match up against
and could advance past the divisional
round I think it's just so hard to say
Dan I'm honestly in any given week you
truly don't know what you're gonna get
from this team I mean this has been the
first year since I've covered them and
I've covered them on and off you know
over a nine-year period this is my
fourth year with the NFL Network
covering them this is the first year
where I really feel like they just
haven't had like this we are identity
and even the defense I was actually
talking to the guys on 105 to the fan
here this pregame we talked so much
about this offense because we're focused
on wow that looks so different it can't
thanks to Jon Kitna and Kellen Moore and
some of the work that he's put in and
where I look at you know Amari Cooper
and Wow Michael gallops really taking
this extra step and Randall Cobbs really
fitting in the system I feel like it was
a bit of a decoy
we weren't focused on the defense and
some of the deficiencies on defense not
to mention some of the injuries and so
this year and then of course special
teams I mean we weren't even paying
attention to how much Bret Maher was
going to be a liability for you but it
just has been so hard for them to piece
it all together it's hard to imagine
that this team can make a run in the
playoffs but then they go out there and
they play a team that it was Eric Weddle
who told me they can't afford to lose
you would have felt like heading into
this game that this was not one that the
Cowboys were going to end up winning 44
to 21
and so I believe that they truly have
bought into this idea as crazy as all of
us on the outside think it is that they
can write a whole the conduct story and
make a run and when I look at the way
the Falcons made the 49ers the way that
the Cowboys have kept it close with not
only the Patriots in those conditions
kept it close with the Saints in New
Orleans if they go on a run they start
believing themselves they start playing
complementary football I've never
thought that the team didn't have the
talent to do it but for whatever reason
they weren't motivated to do it which
was wild but if they play the way they
were last night I think they could make
along as crazy as it sounds it doesn't
sound crazy to me at all I I absolutely
agree and I think that's why so much of
the criticism has fallen on Jason
Garrett fair or not is that people look
at this Cowboys roster on both sides of
the ball and they do have the talent
they're stacked there's a lot of talent
on this football team which is one of
the reasons I believe the Cowboys I
believe in momentum I don't I I think
it's a real thing and you you peak at
the right time in team sports and it
changes everything and the Cowboys could
potentially be peaking at the right time
Jane you you peaked on Twitter last week
with I think it was last week with this
tweet that I just kind of stumbled
across and went viral about your Fitbit
and seeing it spike in the middle of the
night well your boyfriend like did you
have any idea that this was gonna go as
viral as it did no and honestly I wish
it would just die quite frankly and I'm
sure like being a journalist like some
of mine I'm number one is report the
news don't become the news so I can't
imagine my network and love this either
if you know my personality it was sort
of this innocuous tweet where our boy
Albert Brewer had responded to Charles
Robinson over at Yahoo Sports it was all
about this peloton drama and I was just
joking that hey I love health motivated
gifts until I don't and I was just
joking about this Fitbit story that
happens I won't get the time period
because you know I don't I wasn't
certainly looking to drag the accused or
looking for justice we've both very much
moved on but it was sort of a joke that
I would have with girlfriends over
dinner like
I dated this guy once and you know how
ridiculous is this it I caught him this
way and he never you know to this day
was able to come up with a legitimate
excuse for God
activity level spiking when he's not
answering his phone or picking up is
responding to text and I just I really
never thought anything of it and I guess
it was sort of just for whatever reason
I think it shook a couple of men out
there how could you possibly be caught
this way to have this device on me that
can set my you know significant other
can track me I think girls said it's
funny haha you caught him because I have
you know friends that will hold up but
iPhone to a guy's face while he's
sleeping at night to hack its phone and
so I think that I don't think I always
say to men sometimes I think you
underestimate your opponent women are
very savvy at some of these things but I
literally didn't think anything of it
and when it went viral and blew up at
first it was funny then it was sort of
okay now it's a little misleading it's
making it sound like this happened to me
yesterday I'm very upset about it
I want to drag this guy I deserve
justice we've all moved on there's sort
of a backstory of it I haven't really
been interested in talking to all the
news outlets and wanted to get into and
discuss we are of course in the middle
of getting into playoff getting beer and
I've been covering the Cowboys such as
wild and certainly not a storyline that
I can't to really give too much life to
wow people really know people that hold
phones up to their husbands faces while
they're sleeping at night to know you
guys are gonna like get on this like you
guys are so you you underestimate your
opponent that's what I'm going to it
cracks me up you guys are so clueless
sometimes oh that's a valid point I mean
we certainly are Jane Slater I know you
have another live shot for NFL Network
always a pleasure I will see you Super
Bowl week in Miami I hope yes looking
forward to it absolutely good luck the
rest of the way enjoy the ride my friend
all right thanks a bike James Slater so
much fun to talk to inside with the
Cowboys few know more about that
organization than she does for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on Br
or download the Rich Eisen show app